[Musique]
bonsoir mesdames et messieurs l'avenir
de montréal concerne tous les québécois
ce soir compte tenu de l'importance de
l'enjeu nous avons transformé le
téléjournal pour vous proposer un débat
d'une heure entre les deux principaux
candidats à la mairie montréal valérie
plantes bonsoir bonsoir denis coderre
bonsoir merci d'être là vous allez ce
soir dans une formule la plus souple
possible
débattre de cinq thèmes logement
mobilité
sécurité économie services aux citoyens
et environnement chacun aura un temps de
parole équitable qui apparaîtra
d'ailleurs régulièrement l'écran vous
verrez mesdames et messieurs donc où se
sont rendus les deux candidats si vous
parlez en même temps ce sont les
citoyens qui vont perdre puis je vous le
rappelle ray alors bon débat premier
thème incontournable le logement
la question c'est à savoir si les taxes
foncières vont augmenter cet axe bien
avec toujours un fardeau c'est la crise
du logement les gens ont recours aux
dames la hache le jus ça peu de bon sens
comme un test clé logements ont menti
c'est abordable c'est certain que
j'adhère à montréal où choper tellement
charge par les loges mais un prix
modique
beaucoup de monde qu'un nombre de
zombies nom de logement social
cruellement depuis plusieurs années tout
le monde promet des logements mais c'est
vous rien qui a été construit au niveau
des maisons ici c'est pas achetable à
montréal qu'on veut pas vraiment où j'ai
quitté belhaddad berthou de la hausse
des prix on va devoir sortir dé lille
probablement les prix sont pas
accessibles pendant pour acheter ce souk
et services
ça a été le sujet de préoccupation
numéro un quand je me suis promené dans
les rues de montréal pour faire ses
rencontres avec les citoyens la question
est fort simple comment fait-on pour
garder les familles à montréal et
accroître l'offre de logement je vous
donne un seul chiffre et c'est un record
depuis 20 ans il ya trente cinq mille
neuf cents personnes qui ont quitté
l'île de montréal au profit des des
banlieues première deuxième troisième
couronne alors comment on fait pour
garder les gens sur l'île monsieur
coderre vous avez 45 secondes mais dans
un premier temps c'est clair que la
notion de densité est essentiel parce
qu'on peut parler évidemment quand on
parle de logement social c'est une chose
à part on a besoin ya des problèmes
spécifiques à ça mais si on veut avoir
une incidence sur les prix au niveau de
l'habitation pour l'accès à la propriété
et tout ce qui est abordable on a besoin
de doper l'offre là pour ce faire on a
besoin d'une plus grande densité alors
intervient de cette façon là moi je
pense qu'il faut être beaucoup plus
inclusive dans le processus travailler
aussi avec les développeurs tous les to
le type l'institutionnel tous ceux et
celles qui ont un rôle à jouer au niveau
de l'habitation pour qu'on puisse
travailler ensemble on veut tous de la
mixité sociale moi je suis en désaccord
avec le le fameux règlement 20 20 20
parce que je pense que ça s'appelait
l'exode mais on pourrait en parler
pendant le débat mais on a besoin d'une
nouvelle stratégie d'habitation qui soit
beaucoup plus pragmatique et comment on
fait pour garder les gens montréal
valérie plan de 45 secondes oui merci
alors oui effectivement quand on regarde
des villes comme toronto vancouver qui
ont perdu la bataille c'est parce qu'il
y avait pas de réglementation ils ont
laissé le marché
ils l'ont laissé faire qui n'a pas
fonctionné alors pour nous comme
administration pilote renault prochain
mandat on veut continuer de trouver des
solutions qui sont concrètes ça passe
par soixante mille logements abordables
sur dix ans et la façon de le faire
c'est d'acheter les terrains pour garder
un levier pour que ça reste abordable
sur 40 ans parce qu'en ce moment ce qui
se passe c'est que des gens qui prennent
des logements abordables et qui les
transforment ils font des flips et sa
soeur du marché ou si le règlement sur
le 20/20 nous assure que tout le monde
dont les promoteurs immobiliers sont
autour de la table pour avoir 20% de
logement social abordable et familiale
20 % pour chaque et c'est comme ça qu'on
veut conserver la mixité économiques
culturels et sociale de la ville de
montréal merci madame lambert justement
il ya deux visions qui s'affrontent
est-ce qu'on doit et finalement c'est la
question forcer les promoteurs à
construire du logement abordable ce
coderre vous lancer le débat ouvert
est-ce que c'est pas utopique de croire
ça va pousser tout ça mais ce qui est
utopique de penser qu'on va donner des
chiffres pires faut se donner les moyens
de la réalité de les réaliser alors si
on veut travailler et on en a quatre ans
on regarde par rapport aux chiffres ce
qu'on a livré comme marchandise en moi
ce que je dis c'est que oui on a besoin
de réglementation on n'a pas besoin de
règlement qui vont restreindre davantage
est actuellement point de vue de même à
radio canada il y avait des reportages
là dessus avec le 20/20 les gens s'en
vont alors est ce qu'on a besoin d'eux
oui on peut acheter des on peut acheter
des terrains on a d'ailleurs avec le
statut de métropole la crise a forcé les
prendre et ce pas une question de force
et c'est une question de travailler en
équipe et s'assurer que cette inclusion
travail en équipe ça c'est que tu as
fait faisant parce que quand on pense au
projet mon le seul où est ce qu'il y ait
de règlements d'inclusion en fait il
n'était même pas encore en place que
molson montrent un monteur voyons
montoni et le groupe sélection des gros
promoteurs ont dit 'nous on embarque il
y croit alors pour moi cette notion
qu'elle ait tous les promoteurs
immobiliers ne veulent pas de cette
réglementation je n'y crois pas il faut
voir également que les villes comme
gatineau qui regarde notre règlement
petit et je pense et ce que va falloir
qu'on fasse finalement si vous me
permettez dans les cinquante mille
logements que vous pourrez vous
promettez monsieur coderre à cause qu'il
ya aucun règlement pour gérer l'offre de
logements abordables et social les deux
tiers ne seront pas accessibles à la
classe moyenne c'est juste les plus
riches qui vont pouvoir les acheter dans
le centre ville et ça pour moi ce n'est
pas ma définition de la mixité pour moi
c'est pas exactement ce qu'attend on
parle du cinquantenaire à d'habitation
en 4 1 parce qu'il faut livrer la
marchandise on peut donner des chiffres
mais quand on regarde ceux qui habitent
le sonos de problèmes allant de cinq ans
mais le bosphore en quatre ans bao di
mille de logements sociaux on va voir on
va avoir une réglementation souple qui
va nous permettre de travailler mais
quand vous dites par exemple au niveau
de molson il ya un problème parce que
les logements sociaux sont trop élevés à
cause de votre définition de la densité
donc il faut qu'on se donne des outils
pour les moyens pia d'ap je pourrais
vous parler mais la majeure partie des
développeurs son contenu est contre
paris grands principes mais moi j'avance
à vous entendre parler concrètement vous
avez des dix mille logements sociaux
l'espace et des femmes de québec vous ne
parlez pas du logement abordable comment
vont coûter un logement abordable si
aucune réglementation dans le centre
ville et si vous me permettez à ce
niveau-là l'abordabilité surtout celles
qui pérenne celle qui pérenne parce que
ce qu'on veut éviter la c'est que nos
enfants qui n'ont plus d'enfants puisque
jamais habité à mort elle est là dessus
je pense que vous avez un double disque
où on va pas se le cacher votre tante
dans la mairie fait défiler qu'en ce
moment d'anvers dont youtube mais ça
c'est ce que ça envoie aux citoyens qui
aux familles qui veulent installer vote
double et disco l'abordabilité
l'incidence sur les prix ont un lien
direct avec la densité quand vous avez
plus d'offres les prix baissent alors on
n'est pas là pour gérer des prix mais si
on veut travailler en termes d'
abordable il faut les livrer cette
marchandise l'a donc au lieu de donner
des chiffres en asie pendant qu'à dix
ans puis de pérennité pendant 40 ans on
a besoin d'eux chose immédiatement les
gens qui n'ont rien ont besoin de
réalisation immédiate et c'est pour ça
qu'on a bien donné sur roissy je pouvais
définie au moins notre vision chacun
c'est pour moi c'est un droit
fondamental habitation puis pour
monsieur coderre c'est un bien de
consommation sais pas je suis un bien de
consommation parce que vous avez vous
même le monument et moi même on a une
propriété il ya un élément aussi de
stabilité économique avec soi puis il
peut y avoir éventuellement un fonds par
une richesse donc faut faire attention
mais on a besoin de livrer la
marchandise les gens qui posent des
questions lors ce qu'ils veulent c'est
des réponses qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
rapidement très bien les gens aussi voit
l'inflation tout coûte plus cher hydro
on a vu tous les sens la nourriture est
là les teintes il ya méfiant sur les
taxes les gens d'ici l'inflation geste
4,4 un record en dix huit ans pendant
quelques années en tout cas quelques
mois qu'est ce que vous faites avec les
tâches madame plan lui donne la parole
ensuite débat ouvert et se poursuit
qu'est ce que vous faites mais en fait
ce qu'on veut c'est garder les taxes à
l'inflation pendant tout le mandat est
ce qu'on s'est engagé à faire parce que
en sortie de crise économique que
beaucoup plus de fluctuation mais dans
la première année on veut s'assurer de
rester aux 2% ce que le message que
j'envoie aujourd'hui c'est que c'est
l'année d'après là encore une inflation
est à 4.5 on n'ira jamais là l'idée
c'est de nos portes
pour la première oui ça me sens bien
nous ce qu'on a dit depuis le début je
suis content que madame plantées çà au
début c'était que l'inflation près vous
avez des idées pour ça maintenant c'est
votre mandat d'administration qui avait
dit que vous montrez pas les taxes
qu'ils aient augmenté au début de votre
premier mandat moi je pense que nous en
moyenne on est un point 8 % je pense que
la première étape c'est de s'assurer que
l'on puisse se voir comment les dépenses
en sont faites mais on veut que ce soit
1 % la première année ça c'est une
petite ville est là parce que les gens
nous ont tellement écrit au sujet du
programme de remboursement partiel de la
taxe de bienvenue le problème c'est que
le seuil d'admissibilité nam là est
tellement aborde dans la vraie vie vous
vouliez des vingt mille personnes en
assumer le ring on se croit avec soin
avec neige choisir je suis très fier
parce que quand tu arrivé en poste le
plafond à la base y allait à 250 milles
sous l'administration ne se connaît on
le monte entre 450 et jusqu'à 650 me
dans les quartiers centraux mais
clairement on voit que le besoin est là
alors qu'en
réalité c'est qu'il va falloir qu'on se
dise
est-ce qu'on a là la question la taxe de
bienvenue là c'est quelque chose d'un
peu un dessin puis pour se faire si on
dépend notre budget dépend 76 % taxe
foncière donc il est temps qu'on
réévalue ça qu'on dit vers syfy notre
source de revenus et puis qu'on arrête
de tergiverser sur speed peu importe
l'administration je pense qu'il faut
repenser cette question de textes de
permutations pas sa peau de bon sens il
ya des gens qui n'ont pas de logement le
problème de l'itinérance à montréal
écoutez ceci
mais c'est surtout les itinérants
leur trouver
leur trouver des moyens qu'on puisse
nous trouver des moyens pour qu'on
puisse les aider ça prend des gens qui
savent comment remplir la paperasse
ouais parce que souvent le plus cerveau
pour le faire ça prendrait d'avoirs
publics avec des douches publiques juste
pour faire notre lavage pierre aux
toilettes après 10 heures c'est vraiment
compliqué c'est on pense pas seul mais
c'est vraiment et c'est un problème qui
ont un problème
cette dame là c'est comment elle elle
vous dit elle est dans la rue comment
faciliter ma vie oui les grands
principes on veut tous les enlever de la
rue des lavoirs publics des lieux
ouverts madame plantes qu'est-ce qu'on
fait définitivement pendant la coiffure
on a vu que la précarité était exacerbée
au nord un certain qu'on les refuges
parle qu'il ya eu à le doubler le nombre
de personnes en situation d'itinérance
donc clairement oui il faut mettre plus
de refuge ou est-ce que des services
comme des douches des lavoirs mais
honnêtement il faut aussi qu'on sorte de
cette logique été hiver parce que c'est
comme ça que ça fonctionne présentement
le gouvernement du québec est en charge
de l'itinérance au sens très large et le
nous ce qu'on demande c'est un plan sur
cinq ans pour s arrêter de faire des
délits d' urgence l'hiver et l'été on
leur dit bon vin parquet dans la nature
ça ne fonctionne plus et donc on veut
pouvoir des robes de l'argent de québec
que vous dites c'est normal parce que si
on a on est tributaire on s'occupe on
est mandataire de l'itinérance à
montréal mais ça tombe sous le jupon si
je peux dire de la femme je connais ce
dossier là me touche profondément et je
pense pas que ça soit juste la faute à
québec il faut qu'on se prenne en main
c'est la responsabilité de tous on doit
investir on doit s'investir et la
métropole doit voir personne de laissés
pour compte et en ce sens nous avions
omis dès le premier mandat une politique
en ce sens je sens que du côté de
l'administration actuelle on en a pas on
on a un peu pas mal laisser tomber donc
c'est pas juste une question de refuser
une question de transition on doit
mettre de l'avant une nouvelle stratégie
avec les communautaires vous savez que
l'itinérance a plusieurs visages de la
réalité des femmes de l'arrêté
autochtone gardait milton parc c'est un
fléau donc il faut que des gestes posés
très clairement nous on a proposé plus
de 60 millions de dollars en ce sens là
et travailler en collaboration avec les
autres gouvernements mais la ville a une
responsabilité qu'on n'assume pas
présent ok vous me permettez
pendant la cobi dont on a pu voir à quel
point la ville quand elle dit qu'elle ne
laisse personne derrière ces personnes
est tous des itinérants ont été pris en
charge sans entente québec et parce
qu'on travaille en équipe avec les
intervenants communautaires très bien
deuxième thème
ça c'est pas difficile d'avoir des
commentaires des montréalais là dessus
c'est la mobilité
ou à petit l'espace pour les vélos d'une
force pisciculteurs et vélos sur cet
important les routes sont rendus si cela
conduit à cause des pistes cyclables
trop de pistes cyclables un peu d'autres
pistes cyclables
[Musique]
il ya rien de ma vie que les gens sur
quelques 100 vélos puissent cyclades ça
arrange beaucoup de monde mais ça
dérange beaucoup les personnes en
voiture
transpole pas mal déficiente
transparence et en rimes avoir un
meilleur service de transport en commun
akale métro dans l'est
parce que des gros problèmes de
circulation
morel une vie qui est en permanence aux
chaudières ces travaux la coordination
des travaux trafic tellement tapé du
populaire pour stationner et pompiers la
police et les livres harry peuvent pas
circuler passé deux circuits en ville on
dirait que c'est fait exprès oups ça
marche pour
[Musique]
question et vous aurez 45 secondes pour
y répondre est ce que montréal est
condamné à être bloquée mal un plan de
45 soit la réponse est non mais ça fasse
définitivement par une plus grande offre
de transport collectif c'est vraiment ça
la clé et c'est pourquoi depuis quatre
ans notre équipe a tellement mis
d'énergie que ce soit pour la ligne rose
que ce soit pour leur m2 de l'ess que ce
soit pour l'un srb pie-ix la ligne bleue
les 300 autobus parce que ça fasse par
plus de mobilité nécessairement quand on
enlève des gens sur la route quand on
est capable quand ils se retrouvent dans
le transport collectif ça laisse plus de
place également pour les personnes qui
ont besoin de se déplacer en voiture
absolument pour différentes raisons mais
aussi pour tout ce qui touche la
logistique parce que la ville de
montréal est un pôle logistique très
très important alors moi je mise comme
en 2007 sur la mobilité le transport pas
l'excité le transport actif qui est
complémentaire évidemment on va en
reparler bien sûr du transport collectif
de la stm en trop je coderre vaut 45 ans
la mobilité australie ça c'est clair
ce qu'on voit en plus c'est qu'on doive
penser aux piétons les voitures la foire
et aidé et anti voiture faut arrêter de
porc travailler dans un contexte de
cohabitation la voiture et là on peut la
transformer on peut travailler sur
l'autopartage davantage mais il ya des
gens qui ont besoin de leur voiture
quand ils vont amener leurs enfants
l'école quand ils vont chercher des des
commandes quelconque qui est des
réalités de sécurité également on a
besoin d'une vraie cohabitation et
malheureusement c'est pas le cas présent
s'il a des gens qui sont frustrés c'est
aussi à cause de sommet un an pêche pas
qu'on doit avoir une meilleure offre
dont nous parlait du rem leur m2 est
essentiel dans l'est de montréal on doit
repenser aussi à la stm de façon dont
nous voyons
certainement pour moi on a besoin de
ramener cette cohabitation c'est pour un
contrôle les gens nous ont beaucoup dit
qu'on allait les rencontrer l'état des
routes ou si ça valait beaucoup j'aime
bien sûr ma rue pourquoi les budgets
puissant vous donnez trop chief manager
messieurs mais les budgets vous aviez
comment commencer à monter bram plans
des deux premières années
20 et 21 le budget d'entretien des
routes a fondu est-ce que des baux verts
qui commence est ce qu'il n'ya pas un
problème parce qu'on doive apports et on
n'aurait pas dû mettre les bouchées
doubles oui tout à fait pu en fait faut
pas oublier que dans les deux dernières
années pendant la cua ville de pendant
presque je voudrais un bon 8 mois toutes
les opérations étaient vraiment vraiment
diminué donc pour nous de s'occuper des
rues parce que non seulement c'est bon
pour tout le monde s'occupait des routes
là on c'est bon pour les piétons c'est
bon prix cycliste c'est bon pour les
automobilistes donc aucune raison de ne
pas investir massivement et quand on
regarde notre plan triennal
d'investissement la peur qui est donnée
que dans notre budget de fonctionnement
la part qui est prévu pour la réparation
réparation des routes pardon est
importante alors on remet pas en
question est toute douce intéressant
parce que quand on a mis en place
justement le programme de réparation des
routes liot premièrement toute la
question le on voit l'urgence les codes
rouge puis on voulait avoir remplir les
nids de poule et tout ça est votre parti
état compte maintenant on a c'est une
réalité de la vie on au 13 mai le
kilomètre de route dégoupillant que
depuis sa côte 2.1 milliards par année
juste pour la mise à niveau donc il faut
s'assurer que aussi qu'on ait des
produits adéquats pour cela vous vous
souvenez que dans notre mandat c'est
après aussi la commission charbonneau y
avait une incidence des pays avait une
réalité on avait avec l'inspecteur
général on aurait donné la situation de
la corruption et de la collusion absolue
net et cédant 2 30% de moins au niveau
des prix je comprends que les prix sont
très élevés aussi maintenant mais on a
besoin de réparer des rues est sûre si
vous me permettez parce qu'une nuance
affaire c'est que l'ordre quand vous
étiez maire vous faisait des travaux et
vous fermiez ça reste à l'identique si
c'était arrivé que sainte catherine
saint denis et donc nous ce qu'on a
testé en arrivant comme administration
c'est que quand on fait des rénovations
quand on refait une rue on a refait pas
à l'identique on réfléchit à l'externe
la boîte et on regarde quels sont les
besoins des citoyens qui habitent dans
le quartier qui passe à travers le
quartier et moi je constate c'est la
meilleure façon d'utiliser l'argent et
je pense que le rêve saint denis on en
est le meilleur exemple ça avait été
refait à l'identique
on a décidé d'installer une piste clame
un million de passages qui a été
célébrée dimanche et 30 nouveaux
commerces qui se sont installés sur
saint denis alors qu'il était maintenant
vous deux là vous êtes con montréalais
qui aimerait que le russe soit meilleur
état est-ce que ça ça envier à nos fins
et que c'est pas tous les arts tél on va
revenir sur la question de saint denis
c'est 400 m à l'époque parce que les
tuyaux coup les tuyaux couler de partout
puis plus on est longtemps sur un
chantier plus les commerces ferment donc
faut travailler là dessus dans
l'ensemble et en plus vous avez coupé
les subventions au niveau des
infrastructures locales et si une
réalité aussi pour la qualité de vie
pour les artères locale donc on a besoin
de réparer des rues il ya des choses
qu'on doit faire on doit pas tout
repenser tout le temps les rues il ya
des artères on y repense pendant le
faire nous aussi mais un moment donné il
faut être concret il faut s'assurer que
parce que
oui on répare les rues et on travaille
les donneurs d'ouvragé pour s'assurer
que quand la ville ou parce que 25% des
travaux c'est la ville de montréal soit
5,15 pour ça ce sont d'autres donneurs
d'ouvragé compagnies de
télécommunications d'énergie des
propriétaires privés alors nous on aide
à coordonner parce que on ne veut pas
qu'il ya un trou qu'ils se fassent par
la ville s'est refermée qui hydro québec
ouattara d'un plateau j'ai une question
pour glace j'ai une question pour vous
deux qui pourrait aider la mobilité et
l'environnement et la qualité de vie des
montréalais
c'est les gros camions qui font de la
livraison dans les quartiers à aurillac
comment ça se fait que c'est encore
permis à leurs gilets en tant que vous a
parlé on est mis en place le projet
colibri qui viendra non encore mais oui
mais je d'accord mais on est mis en
place un projet pilote pour amener du
transport électrique des plus petits
véhicules ou même des vélos cargo dans
le centre-ville entre autres où il ya
des camions qui arrivent un centre de
transbordement qui est à l'ancienne gare
voyageurs et à partir de là le dernier
kilomètre ce fait on transporte beaucoup
plus petit beaucoup plus doux plus
sécuritaire et c'est ça qu'il faut faire
pour préserver la sécurité de nos
milieux dits oui on a beaucoup
d'arrivées a retiré camion n'avait été
c'est qu'on se parle points si on doit
on devait faire ce sommet du camion
qu'on veut faire pour avoir une
stratégie de l'ivresse ça se fait dans
d'autres grandes villes du monde si on
dit par exemple 9 heures puis 11 heures
le matin là ça va être la livraison
premièrement vous allez désengorger
certains secteurs ça va être d'autant
plus sécuritaire mais il faut aussi
penser que au niveau des camions la
sécurité c'est important de toutes les
jaquettes et puis comme on a fait dans
le sound propre matériel roulant
montréal
mais les gens veulent des solutions
maintenant des camions électriques et
des vélos cargo ça marche c'est ça
l'avenir c'est ce que toutes les grandes
du monde alors nous pousser cette unité
le bien le pour le transfert énergétique
je peux plein avec ça mais le commerçant
qui a besoin de vendre ces choses ou
bien expliqué besoin de ces fruits frais
ça fait partie de la qualité de vie
oscille donc ci est bloqué parce que les
routes sont trop restreints de si on
n'est pas capable
vous avez parlé vous deux des vélos des
du rêve sur saint denis ya et regarder
sa yam où 1 1 million en 2020 de
montréalais qui ont fait du vélo c'est
une augmentation de 42% par rapport à
est-ce que la résumer mois soit
clairement souley est ce qu'on doit
faire plus de pistes cyclables est ce
qu'on doit faire moins de tesla monsieur
coderre a les humains il faut les en
faire plus mais de façon intelligente
comme on le fait par exemple pour le
rêve saint denis le rêve des chars sont
en train de faire le rêve sur pie xi en
même temps c'est des projets qui
prennent à peu près trois ans
planification qui s'assure que la
sécurité des piétons des cyclistes et au
final moi je veux dire quand on parle de
mobilité mon cutter numéro un c'est la
sécurité sur saint denis il y avait eu
plus de 300 collision dont trois morts
il était temps d'âge et on ne fait le
rêve est maintenant la circulation et
apaisée c'est complètement un autre
milieu de vie qu'on a qu'on a dû en
effet il ya aucun anti vélo ici moi
aussi j'en fais du vélo mais un moment
donné il faut travailler en termes de
cohabitation un des problèmes vous avez
les voitures versus les cyclistes les
cyclistes versus les piétons et c'est un
problème donc et puis quand on fait une
piste cyclable sécurisée ou non si on
donne l'impression qu'on le fait à un
moment où on a l'impression qu'on soit
faire une passe parce que paul de
consultation c'est un problème aussi
dont on ne veut pas de problème on avait
le meilleur plan vélo d'ailleurs vélo
québec en 2010 est le type de continuer
ce continent
de façon très concrète mais on a besoin
de se retrouver là prenez besoin d'une
meilleure cohabitation et mais on veut
réduire le nombre de voitures sur
l'autopartage peut se faire
je peux vous dire c'est que je suis
c'est vrai que ça a été difficile pour
les commerçants de la rue saint denis la
d re l'année dernière pour nous
d'essayer dédommager les dédommager pour
certaines pertes mais vous rendez vous
compte à quel point quand on parle d'une
relance verte et inclusive la leur et
hameçonner un symbole hyper concret où
justement on est en train de revoir nos
analyses nos façons de vie dans la ville
est encore une fois en ayant la place
pour tout le monde un des commentaires
que j'entends beaucoup sur saint denis
des autobots automobilistes qui me
disent je le sais où aller les vélos
sont là aussi ça fait mon affaire yes ou
faut changer nos comportements
mais l'idée que le jeu de piste cyclable
est fait de façon intelligente sur les
grands axes 8 mai notre 16 vous deux
les télés radios ne vous inquiétez pas
je le regarde monsieur monsieur coderre
madame plante une question avant de
clore ce débat la stm un déficit de 62
millions est-ce qu'on va être obligé de
couper des services et donc il ya encore
cinquante cinq pour cent de
l'achalandage simplement aujourd'hui le
rapport à grimper qu'est-ce qu'on fait
que le déficit monsieur prix la réalité
c'est que les cantons qu un dollar d'une
place ces points dollars d'économies à
la stm parce que 70 % des exploitations
c'est des salaires donc si on veut
couper dans les semble pas couper dans
les services premièrement c'est ce que
la responsabilité de la ville parce que
la stm sur un budget de la ville donc il
peut combler ce déficit là mais si on ne
veut pas couper les services se 30% la
faute reprendre un service administratif
se dit qu'on devra obligé de couper 50%
des services administratifs de lester
alors concrètement ce qu'il faut c'est
le nom de ne pas affecter le transport
l'offre de service parce que si on veut
ramener les gens dans les autobus qui
est absolument nécessaire
il faut pas que l'oeuvre soit moins
important au bout d'une heure non mais
non sinon d'ailleurs chassé pendant
l'aquavit j'avais tenu à garder les
services parce qu'on savait qu'ils
avaient plein d'infirmières des gens de
première ligne qui prenait le métro pas
question d'ajouter un temps d'arrêt
voilà aucune coupure
faire ce qu'ils vont pouvoir faire c'est
de l'acupuncture bien sûr sur certaines
lignes de faire de l'optimisation mais
pour moi de garder la qualité de service
est absolument crucial si on avait pour
donner le plein service mais des
services
pendant la pandémie on serait pas dans
cette situation là aujourd'hui c'est des
gens les ce thème un peu mais c'est déjà
important
les gens ont besoin d'aller à l'avant et
d'avoir
ça a changé en aura d'autobus europe
auto sa demande six mois d'avancé ce que
vous savez la même plante
malheureusement c'est que si on est
obligé de couper dans les services là
c'est encore plus de monde qui vont être
touchés devant moi
et je suis très fier de l'avoir fait
d'avoir mis des vignettes avoir mis du
stationnement gratuit d'avoir gardé tous
les services de contact c'est pas tout
le monde loin de voitures monsieur
coderre prochain thème
la sécurité
point de vue sécurité là c'est très
important pour moi ça c'est la sécurité
je ne sens pas assez lutté
avec les armes à feu beaucoup plus de
contrôle plus de sécurité qu'est ce
qu'ils vont faire dans le plan de
financement de la police c'est sûr pour
nos besoins de prise de policiers s'est
rendu que c'est on ne parle plus de
sécurité ce nombre de ménages
plus de sécurité a dit cette dame sinon
je déménage alors ça fait les manchettes
régulièrement vous le voyez ça c'est les
incidents impliquant des armes à feu à
montréal de 41 en 2019 on est rendu à 97
puis c'est pas tout à fait il y en a eu
d'autres pierres par exemple plus
qu'hier soir exactement monsieur coderre
à ce que montréal est encore une ville
sécuritaire 45 sur vauréal dépôt
sécuritaire présentement dans le
reconnaissant elle peut le redevenir et
c'est pour cette raison qu'aujourd'hui
dans notre plan on a dit qu'il faut non
seulement augmenter les effectifs donc
le plafond étant à 4800 nous sommes à
4520 on doit on doit les augmenter
davantage donc on va faire ça donc le
prêt de 7 novembre on va augmenter
l'effectif pour vos demandes à québec
même d'augmenter le plafond à 5109
besoin on a besoin de moderniser l'espm
également qu'ils ont besoin d'outils on
me dit que même dans certains éléments
dans les armes intermédiaires ils sont
désuètes puis en ont besoin mais on doit
on doit travailler aussi pour les
caméras portatives ces caméras
portatives la pointe est essentielle
mais il faut travailler aussi avec le
communautaire et augmenter
les escouades mixant 60 merci monsieur
coderre madame plantes oui merci
beaucoup oui ça a été une année
difficile pour les montréalais et
montréalaises
on sort de là covin pendant la cabine
tout le monde était chez soi quand on a
commencé à réouvrir le crime organisé
l'uci a pris la place puis s'est modifié
je pense qu est ce qui est important
c'est de pouvoir amener des solutions
qui sont très concrètes comme nous on le
fait depuis le départ depuis le début
parce que c'est un
comment dire c'est une situation qui
évolue ceci étant dit qu'on aura la
chance d'en parler mais de là à dire
qu'elle avait des dangereuses non de la
bouche du candidat à la mairie crocus et
mettre de côté tout le travail de celles
et ceux qui assurent notre protection
les organismes communautaires que j'ai
envie de vous dire même tous nos
partenaires de l'écosystème économique
tourisme au real et autres qui font des
pieds des mains les universités qui
essaie d'amener les étudiants et le
message pour l'heure si c'est que
montréal est dangereuse je trouve que
c'est irresponsable donc vous dites
qu'on va trop loin car c'est l'image
absolument le nombre de policiers par
cent mille habitants c'est important de
venir montrer parce qu'on a l'impression
qu'il y en a beaucoup moins c'est faux
il y en a plus à montréal 220 par cent
mille habitants winnipeg 177 toronto on
a moins de policiers par cent mille que
toronto est ce que c'est vraiment la
solution de mettre plus de policiers
monsieur coderre des bovins tout à fait
c'est une des solutions et vous savez
quand on se promène sur le terrain les
gens ont parlé gens ont même des dix
pensent que on les voit pas pourquoi
parce qu' il manque 2 153 effectifs
parce que vous avez des des gens qui
sont complètement à terre qu'il y aurait
une réalité aussi au niveau des
policiers là quand on oblige des
policiers dans un poste comme le poste
21 de travailler quatre obligatoirement
avec du temps supplémentaire au bout de
la ligne
d'en but il incarne un besoin qu'un vent
que ce soit alors oui les policiers pour
toujours à chaque année quand un départ
à la retraite pouvoir pallier à ces
besoins la en d'année en année ça va
près entre 120 et 180 cette année nous
on en a mis deux cent vingt la prochaine
année ça va être 220 également mais vous
savez ce que il manque vraiment un
élément dans ce que vous dites monsieur
connaît ici même pas dans votre plan de
ce matin c'est l'apport également du
communautaire d'ailleurs votre plan
n'est pas chiffré alors les 250
policiers vous ne l'avez pas chiffré et
moi je pense que les mots rialet quand
on voit la lumière des chiffres
importants du roman y aller qu'est-ce
qu'on va investir dans les quatre
prochaines années nous c'est 110
millions sur trois axes qui sont
chiffrées le premier c'est pour elle t'a
ya le trot trafic d'armes ensuite c'est
pour les groupes contre les groupes
criminalisés et finalement tout le
travail du communauté ça c'est les gens
qui sont sur le terrain qu'ils
connaissent les familles qui ont une
capacité d'aller intervenir de faire des
programmes de prévention qui sont
complémentaires à la police nous allons
tous les candidats millions de plus pour
les quatre prochaines années pour mieux
ça va coûter monsieur coderre j'avais
manqué une belle confiance de price
parce que les augmenter les effectifs
ces 120 millions sur quatre ans des
caméras portatives c'est 30 millions sur
quatre ans donc oui puis on a parlé non
seulement on a parlé du communautaire
mon veut s'investir dans le
communautaire vous avez fait même une
conférence de presse l'autre fois avec
les policiers vous mêmes pour inviter
fait qu'on n'a pas de leçons à recevoir
mais on doit
chiffrer le montant pour la communauté à
votre goût du communautaire et les
montants qu'ils voient qu'ils vont être
nécessaires il a des dizaines de
millions qui sont rattachés à ça mais ce
qu'on a besoin parce qu'on sait qu'à
chaque dollar qu on investit dans le
communautaire on en sauve ça alors on
veut travailler ensemble mais il faut
arrêter de prendre la police comme juste
l'outil de coercition c'est aussi et y
ont aussi un rôle social à jouer on peut
tirer toutes les lettres de l'alphabet
pour faire des escouades la réalité
c'est que depuis deux ans sans rampi et
puis on a besoin de donner des outils
tant au niveau policier qu'au niveau
comme notre
débat désistement parce que l'année
dernière pour se rappeler que les
policiers de la ville de montréal gérer
un couvre feu c'est ça qui faisait là un
couvre-feu entre autant il fallait pas
les itinérants devait rentrer à une
certaine heure le gouvernement du québec
l'avait demandé donc ça c'est à l'année
dernière et en novembre monsieur caron
les chefs de police nous dit madame
plantes on sent qu'il va y avoir une
recrudescence quand on voit sauter de
déconfinement dès le mois de décembre on
a mis un temps l'escouade eu lieu pour
le trafic data que pour vous ce point
important mais très laid cette escouade
là c'est 450 âmes à partir de janvier
compte et retirer une 28 arrestations
donc pour moi d'agir de façon
cohérente et globale et c'est pour ça
pour moi de ne pas nommer dans votre
sortie le communautaire comme il se doit
avec démonta alors qu'ils font le
travail colossal je trouve que c'est un
acte eux mangé pendant ce point d'actes
manqués c'est que vous avez eu une
vocation tardive sur la question de
sécurité maintenant vous vous en occupez
mal à vous été volé faisait était là
pendant quatre ans dis moi c'est moi je
peux le maire je veux le devenir je veux
leur devenir rien à voir mais sur le
terrain les gens ont peur les gens ont
besoin d'outils les gens besoin de
d'avoir plus de policiers sur le terrain
puis on doit aussi pire c'est que là
qu'on a fait le moratoire sur la
question des postes de quartier on
comprenne à l'époque mais là on doit
aussi assurer une présence à rivière des
prairies par pointeau on a besoin de
chacun d'un poste de quartier cette
présence physique et cette présence
exceptionnelle les caméras portatives si
la nouvelle panacée tout le monde est
d'accord vous aviez dit non après un
projet pilote
dans les coins si les enjeux premier
sanjou fait ça est ce que vraiment vous
pensez que ça peut changer la dynamique
entre autres sur le profilage racial
quel est l'objectif en fait oui ça va
changer ça va changer parce que
pour moi il ya plusieurs outils pour
année la transparence et d'imputabilité
puis pour protéger autant les citoyens
mais également les policiers donc les
caméras portatives mais aussi une
politique d'interpellations ça
n'existait pas au québec montréal a
lancé ce projet là alors pour moi c'est
plusieurs outils c'est aussi grâce à la
commission de la sécurité publique que
nous avons rendu public parce qu'avant
ça se passait derrière des portes closes
on a décidé qu'à transparence était
important donc il faut plusieurs outils
pour rassurer la population mais
également pour que metropolis et de bien
faire leur statut vous êtes d'accord
également mené il ya d'autres villes au
canada qu'il utilise la grc veulent la
voir également celui c'est un peu comme
le principe des des caméras dans les
taxis quand on sait qu on est surveillé
quant on sait qu'on est capable de voir
aussi l'autre côté de la médaille sur le
plan ou au niveau même de ce qui se
passe dans ton environnement ça va avoir
un impact
il ya toute la question de la plus de
des données privées la gestion des
données privées sur c'est correct mais
on a notre besoin je suis content
maintenant que me soyez d'accord on peut
juste pas d'accord avec votre projet
pilote qui était mal attachés d'ailleurs
on à l'impôt pu s'en servir comme
excuse non c'est différent de ne pas
avoir des données qu'on aurait pu se
servir en cours je pense que les caméras
pour sa missive la première raison c'est
de pouvoir après ça ça nous sert en bon
comme policier ou comme citoyenne
labardin table économie et vous allez
voir ça va être tout c'est un thème très
concret services aux citrons
qu'est ce que la mairie pourrait faire
pour améliorer l'accessibilité à
universelle où l'état des trottoirs au
cices toujours très agréable
c'est comme mes taxes ou en groupe
photographiée sur l'édifice et beaucoup
des édifices trouviez c'est tout mais
kenny ses doigts qu'on a des belles
choses qui qu'on nomme bien les
entretenir
la propreté montréal pauvreté les rues
qui s'est pas vraiment après il ya des
déchets partout je trouve que c'est pas
une ville propre
ou
ailleurs moi je serai candidat à la
mairie chat me ferait mal d'entendre ça
on peut importe montréal qui a encore
perçu par trop de citoyens comme une
ville sale 45 secondes chacun madame
plan et pour moi ce qui est important ce
sur quoi on doit agir c'est
définitivement on vous l'avait dit les
services aux citoyens parce que à la
base une ville ça s'occupe du
déneigement du nettoyage à l'offre
également desservir 70 de toutes sortes
a les permis et autres mais c'est normal
que les montréalais montréalaise
s'attendent à ce que ça se passe bien
alors autant le déneigement s'il ya des
responsables qui sont en arrondissement
et à la ville et on doit avoir une
meilleure concertation ça s'est beaucoup
améliorée depuis qu'on est équipé par
exemple les camions de gps dont des
affaires très concret mais aussi au
niveau des poubelles ce qu'on a ou de la
propreté on a rajouté des escouades il
faut continuer à le faire entre autres
aussi s'occuper des équipes pour
déneiger pour les personnes à mobilité
réduite également mais ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que tout doit être fait
parce que d'une certaine façon ça
contribue également au sentiment de
sécurité mais également à la bonne
économie de montréal merci monsieur
coderre à 45 secondes
non je suis promené dans vies lavez les
salles
le monde boisseau on dépense un budget
maintenant quand je t'ai 2,7 milliards
de dollars les gens ont l'impression
qu'ils ont peu plus de services alors on
reconnaît qu'un problème et puis on a
besoin un peu comme fait
morial centre-ville avec les sdc pour
évidemment quand on parle de propreté et
responsabiliser tout non de celle
affaire de tous mais il ya un problème
alors on regarde ce qui se passe pendant
quatre ans on voit que de plus en plus
de graffitis tout ça c'est ce que c'est
toujours un éternel recommencement
mais il faut qu'on travaille en priorité
donc la question de la propreté ça c'est
essentiel dans les parcs dans les rues
dans les ruelles nous on dit qu'au
niveau de la société de développement
pour le centre-ville en permettant un 10
millions et un autre 50 millions au
niveau des autres sd c'est donc pour ça
mais là dessus ça les ressources mais
faut pas déconner vous allez continuer
en débat ouvert votre 45 secondes et
termine et je veux qu'on entente parce
que ça y'a la propreté ça sort davantage
l'été au printemps aussi quand la neige
fond mais il ya l'hiver et l'hiver à
montréal une relation parfois difficile
on va écouter une dame une part de
trottoir est-ce qu'ils ont des plans
pour changer leur politique de
déneigement de déglaçage des trottoirs
est ce que ça va resté pareil ou est ce
que on va continuer à vivre la même
situation que depuis plusieurs années on
avait moi j'avais désespoir là pour
valérie plante est arrivé au pouvoir
cela met la mairesse de la mobilité mais
si on peut pas sortir de chez soi pour y
aller jusqu'au métro là on ne prendra
pas le métro
alors la même question qui lance le
débat est ce que on doit imaginer
d'autre façon de nettoyer de déglacer
les trottoirs en ville malin planches
dans nos paroles d'un côté oui il faut
absolument innover
tantôt je parlais des déchets n'y est
fait le pas précisé ses déchets niet qui
sont équipés de gps ne serait ce que
pour s'assurer que toutes les routes
sont faits il ya vraiment un partage des
responsabilités entre l'arrondissement
et la ville puis des fois je vous dirais
que ça se passe bien d'autres fois c'est
plus difficile mais au final nous ce
qu'on veut c'est donner le plus d'outils
possible pour que les arrondissements
prennent les meilleures décisions
possibles par exemple il peut faire un
chargement de plus que dans un autre
arrondissement c'est le juge que c'est
pertinent alors on est vraiment dans
cette habileté dans cette flexibilité
qui vont nous permettre bien sûr de
déglacer également je vous cacherais pas
oui les changement climatique nous
affecte mais on doit absolument en est
une r ça fait depuis toujours qu'on gère
la neige là je vous dirais que le gros
défi c'est de maintenance avoir encore
mieux gérer la glace en période de gel
et de dégel on débat ouverte je suis
content qu'on suit la politique qu'on
avait mis des vins parle au début mais
je comprends la
médecine ou non changer même plus on le
fait c'est un essence ont d'ailleurs une
chroniqueuse ici maintenant le problème
est le suivant c'est que on a un manque
le bateau sur l'accessibilité
universelle
quand on parle de trottoirs n'ont pas de
poids juste de déneigement nappy de
déglaçage n'ont pas le même en plein été
donc il faut assurer qu'on ait cette
sensibilité là et qu'on met en priorité
ceux des glaçages la seconde question tu
pas nous a dit abbas et l'arrondissement
on à s'occuper puits d'eau il doit pas
avoir une mauvaise porte quand on a
besoin de services alors on va s'en
occuper on va travailler de cette façon
là on a on va mettre en place aussi une
stratégie avec les sd c'est que j'ai
parlé tantôt avec les partenaires pour
qu'on puisse s'en occuper et
malheureusement quand on parle
d'accessibilité universelle
ils pensent ils se considèrent comme des
soins de seconde classe parce qu'ils
peuvent pas sortir ou quand ils sortent
le tènement toupie ya même des années
passant nous pensons aussi à nos années
il a aucun problème majeur présent
justement parlons d'accessibilité
universelle il ya eu cette dame que j'ai
rencontré à rosemont bien me montrer là
les trois magasins pourraient pas entrer
clé la poussette là on l'étend bientôt
2022 à ce que c'est pour une obligation
comme une vue pour une ville comme
montréal de d'accélérer et rendre les
commerces accessibles la réponse est oui
oui je pourrais toujours vous évitez
tous les détails du domaine bâti le
stade ira la grandeur des trottoirs les
façades les patrimoines archives des
bâtiments patrimoniaux
mais la réponse est oui et de la même
façon que notre administration a fait
avancer comme jamais la rénovation des
des entrées de métro des stations de
métro pour qu'elle soit toujours plus
accessible et de 6,27 c'est l'ensemble
du réseau qui valait donc ça c'est
vraiment impressionnant donc pour nous
que ce soit de mettre des brigades qui
vont aider des personnes âgées ou des
personnes à mobilité réduite à des
neiges leur rentrée en premier parce
qu'on veut qu'ils puissent être plus
mobiles possibles on a décidé de
prioriser également tous les abords des
hôpitaux des métros pour encore une fois
tenté le plus rapidement possible de
l'année échappe rendu là bas et on veut
le faire on sait qu'on va le faire non
on l'interrogeait n'était pas là le
problème le problème d'accessibilité
universelle dont il ya des gens on peut
avoir des bonnes politiques puis gardé
la gelée vécu moi aussi il ya un
problème au niveau de haut niveau des
services et la livraison des services
donc on a besoin d'avoir une voix qui va
être capable d'assurer connaît cette
sensibilité continuons nos des
candidates qui est qui ont qui
représente cela mais je pense qu'on a
besoin d'aller plus loin et c'est pour
ça qu'on a proposé un commissaire ou une
commissaire à l'accessibilité
universelle on a besoin d'avoir des voix
à l'intérieur pour assurer d'une plus
grande imputabilité pour la fonction
publique comme proposant camillo in
commissaire mais ce que je peux vous
dire moi c'est encore une fois c'est du
très concret quand on voit que les gens
qui se sont inscrits sur une liste pour
que leur entrée ou leur descente
d'escalier soit déblayé en priorité puis
que ça marche moi ça me fait extrêmement
plaisir c'est la bonne chose à faire est
de montréal on en parle beaucoup avec
raison ça a été un
régions oubliées
déserté pendant des années vous nous
proposez dans cette campagne électorale
de développer l'est en priorité qui est
le mieux placé pour y arriver débat
c'est nous c'est nous parce que nous
pendant notre mandat on a décidé que
c'est une priorité on ne s'est pas
réveillé ma tendance et une reste
important l'est de montréal donc je suis
très fier de dire que cette déclaration
connaît cynique madame rouleau et tous
les justes qui qui ont suivi au niveau
de la décontamination d'ailleurs parce
que je pense que monsieur coderre va
aller là dessus faut savoir quelle
france cette demande sont présentement
étudiées pour pouvoir décontaminer mais
vous savez ce dont je suis le plus fier
c'est que par rapport au réel de l'est
nous on a décidé qu'on n'attendait pas
que le train passe on a décidé ce matin
d'injecter 500 millions de dollars pour
s'assurer que leur m2 laisse un projet
qui est absolument essentiel dans lequel
on croit profondément assez pour y
investir 500 millions de dollars pour
qu'il soit exemplaire et qu'il rende à
l'intérieur des quartiers de façon
harmonieuse pendant trois ans si je me
suis réveillé le mais j'étais 45 ans à
montréal mais on est toujours sensible à
cette question de l'est de montréal
madame rouleau oui je le connais bien
les membres de mon comité exécutif oui
des réalités de décontamination parce
que sur ça
mais une chose est certaine c'est que on
doit faire plus pour doit faire mieux
donc avec le statut de métropole que
nous nous sommes donné on a maintenant
des outils qui vont nous permettre de
travailler en conséquence d'un niveau de
l'habitation au niveau de la
diversification économique
on veut créer le silicon valley vers
police de montréal mais il faut
s'occuper faut s'occuper de la mobilité
donc on va tous travailler en ce sens
mais on a une équipe qui non seulement
mx qui connaît bien les de montréal vous
avez des karine boivin roi qui va faire
un travail extraordinaire comme mairesse
pour mercier hochelaga maisonneuve
nous n'aurons pas de problèmes sur les i
gr dans le faux bon on va leur église
c'est des petites choses j'adhère vous
avez temmar qui vous n'avez rien fait
pour laisse donc à la limite tous les
deux là on a pas une feuille de route
aux noms comme commanderait une feuille
avec des éléments et pourlèche rien qui
a été fait quand vous étiez maire ni
pour montréal nord alors là dessus pour
l'efs de montréal je te dire à ceux qui
nous écoutent contraire que notre
dévouement et l'intérêt qu'on a pour
l'ess il est réel on vient tout juste de
se réveiller garder leurs dépôts
personnes qui se réveille le plan to
respect demandé à la communauté commun
on a fait rayonner montréal qu'on a
travaillé pour redonner on en a conclu
la renaissance de cette ville bien tant
sur le plan économique sur le plan
social sur le plan environnemental
également donc ce point de comparaison
10,4 et ceci non non on a travaillé
et je suis très fier de mon bilan
pour le développement économique de
l'est cela dit quatre ans pour le faire
et vous n'avez pas bougé moi j'ai bougé
mais moi j'ai pas la
différence vous avez des leurs pendant
quatre ans vous êtes on est en train de
préparer des affaires en train de
préparer le saviez mais des conditions
gagnantes pour leur m2 laisse alors que
vous votre formation politique a dit non
on n'en veut pas de conduire en
conseillers en conseil municipal
monsieur madame
on
est d'accord même du oui/non sur le
produit la france
compte chacun leur m2 laisse même s'il
propose un petit souterrain au
centre-ville petit donc vous allez
signer sur ce contrôleur vous êtes
d'accord qu'ils soient aérienne qu'on
soit clair second mais voilà nous on est
mis des conditions le rem 1.0 y avait
pas de conditions puis on doit vivre
avec des problèmes maintenant nous ce
qu'on dit c'est le tracé en souterrain
doit être évaluée dans mercy est comme
ses demandés mais également dans notre
secteur un domergie absolument mais ça
c'est un processus le leadership c'est
s'assurer qu'on fasse partie de la
décision donc les leaders
de ces partis dont ça va bien on va voir
on va trés ce code a conclu au niveau du
rein on a besoin du hem parce que
justement comme godless de montréal on a
été les parents au pis si on veut des
projets structurants on a besoin du
règne de l'instinct savoie et des
alérions à l'économie et à la mobilité
l'environnement on écoute des sites web
[Musique]
le sujet que vous prie de voir qu'est ce
qui peut faire de plus pour
l'environnement pour conserver des
espaces verts
environnement avant tout mais surtout au
niveau du recyclage
chaque fois je vais prendre un café on
donne un couvercle que je les jetais
pour mon plus occupation c'est surtout
pour les changements climatiques et la
façon qu'on peut être réduire les
pollutions qu'on peut réduire les
émissions
nous avons diffusé un sondage la semaine
dernière d'abord qui vous plaçait coude
à coude mais qui montrait que 60 % des
montréalais
est d'accord pour interdire les
véhicules à essence au centre-ville donc
on a fait du chemin depuis est ce que
vous seriez prêt à les interdire plus
rapidement monsieur coderre quand vous
n'avez pas si oui parce que quand
montréal est devenu membre sur notre
leadership de ses cartes on parlait déjà
on passe d'une maison en bois le veau je
croise en 2035 qui est pas de voiture
essence qui est des voitures électriques
on le sait cette décès dans cette foulée
là qu'on a commencé des bandes de
recharge donc la réponse est oui parce
qu'on doit assurer de cette transition
là et de se donner des paramètres il
faut que nous soyons car bonheur pour
nous c'est 2045 qu'on ait un budget
carbone aussi en ce sens mais on a
besoin nécessairement de d'arrêter avec
des les voitures essence puis je pense
que on avait déjà commencé ça se
poursuit puis je pense que tout le monde
d'accord avec ceux éventuellement très
bien madame plantes ce qu'on doit
accélérer
l'interdiction de tout véhicule à
essence au centre-ville dans la réponse
est oui et nous on l'a mis à l'intérieur
d'un plan climat qui a été fait par une
quantité d'experts dans le domaine
environnemental mais également d'une
nuit au niveau économique et sociale
mentionné et tout le monde était
d'accord pour dire que la relance verte
et inclusive c'est absolument nécessaire
moi j'ai envie de vous dire que cette
élection si elle est fondamentale parce
qu'il faut se positionner pour
aujourd'hui et pour demain il faut
décider quelle équipe est véritablement
est vraiment engagée et sérieuse prête à
faire des gestes courageux puis pas
toujours facile pour vraiment nous
amener valeur carboneutralité et dans ce
plan climat dont je vous parle on parle
de réduire le gaspillage alimentaire
vestimentaire c'est nous qui avons
décidé d'interdire l'usagé plastique une
éco m'ont vu la dame avec sa tasse de
café et on a on ajoute mme hilborn
d'électrification parce que c'est une
des clés dont celui du transport alors
pour nous c'est absolument essentiel et
nous aurons ce courage comme on le
ferait pas merci
servier souvent une question et prenons
le cas du golf d'anjou
de vision que vous n'avez pas la même
vision placement plusieurs sujets vos
visions se sont rapprochés le
commentaire que je referme la parenthèse
pour le golf d'anjou est ce qu'on
protège où on développe en pro tech
débat on développe mais on peut pas
faire du développement économique au
détriment du développement vert parce
qu'à partir de maintenant il n'y a pas
de plan b à la planète mais on a besoin
de créer de la richesse pour les
redistribuer mais il faut s'assurer
qu'on combatte les inégalités alors dans
ce sens là non il n'y a personne qui est
plus environnementalistes que l'autre on
est tous content la réponse n'est donnée
monsieur godard musique le développement
primer sur lesquels on verra si j'ai dit
voilà ouverte et inclusive
ça veut dire qu'on fait une grille
d'analysé sur les projets et vous êtes
prêt à développer sur le dernier espace
vert d'anjou pour moi c'est un non sens
parce que vous savez très bien ma pensée
c'est que de nos jours il faut acheter
des terrains à forts coûts les
décontaminer qu'après sa liberté alors
nous sommes que la logique comme on l'a
fait que l'europe de l'ouest c'est de
regarder les espaces sous le regard du
fait qu'au dialogue avec le dal pas on
peut faire absolument y apparaît pour
mettre les pendules à l'heure y a
personne ici que tu dis que c'est le
développement économique au détriment du
développement vert on a toujours
travaillé en ce sens copie on n'a plus
le choix de faire de toute façon mais à
un moment donné on peut faut pas dire on
va acheter des terrains puis on n'a pas
tout l'argent pour les payer l'eau
élément que j'aime ça vous êtes audace
alors dassieu zola pourquoi qu'on n'a
pas encore interdit de mazout qui vous
l'aviez dans les bâtiments puis vous
aviez dit que vous étiez pour le père
dit
on s'en va sur un élément très précis
écoutez ça va faire plaisir de tous les
temps alors étant donné que dans notre
plate forme douce et des éléments très
concrets l'interdiction du mazout est
déjà prévu pour le niveau institutionnel
en premier la pression au niveau
résidentiel et vous savez ce qu'on fait
c'est con parce que justement nous on
accompagne les citoyens ya plein de gens
dont des personnes aînées dans leurs
vieilles maisons qu'on est trop haut
mais il faut les nuits on est loin de
mettre un programme pour les accompagner
parce que moi je considère que les
changements que sont pas faciles à ce
qu'on la différence g sur le mazout
voulais c'est que nous faisons
nettoyer les pour le bois il faudra bois
puis bon on a dit on va le faire dont on
s'est donné une séquence
au niveau du mazout vous irez vous étiez
pour dire que vous étiez pour
l'interdire dans les bâtiments pourquoi
qu'il prend directement fois que c'est
possible quand est ce que vous l'avez
fait parce qu'on travaille entre autres
avec la cmm c'est vous qui adorez
travail et qui dit souvent qu'il faut à
travailler avec la cmm moi je suis très
fier de dire que le programme moi je
fais pas jusqu'où paix vous avez coupé
pour le lit pour avoir pillé beaucoup de
commerçants qui ont dit mais pourquoi
est-ce qu'on nous enlève notre moyen de
survivre moi ce que je fais je vois pas
mettre dans le trouble des familles où
les accompagnaient ont
peu plus cher maître monsieur
on est sur un aspect très très
particulier mais au final quand on
regarde et j'invite la population
regarder la plateforme environnementale
entre deux équipes et on voit clairement
qu'il va décider
j'invite les gens à comparer les deux
les deux plateformes et vous allez voir
que quand on parle en termes de concret
c'est au plus haut niveau dans un mois
on peut vouloir planter 500 milliards
mais nous on veut s'assurer que chaque
crue ne soit pas sans âme et ça ça va
avoir un impact sur les îlots de chaleur
sur l'acquis sable de verdissement voire
améliorer la qualité de vie des gens
mais je vous invite à poser vos
règlements dans un premier temps puis
après je vous invite à re et être coupé
des arbres comme sont au parc
jean-drapeau et maintenant dit que vous
allez en planter on sait pas combien on
ne sait pas où ça ce n'est pas concret
me sentais pas bien où vous allez
planter des arbres alors si je m'étais
jamais dans toutes les revues à grand
palais dans saint-michel tulle et on
peut se promener on va aller dans un
endroit sans vous dites que c'est
concret faut avoir rappelé à avoir des
objectifs et dans votre plat il n'y a
rien que vous devez vous allez voir les
gens m'ont compagne pendant la pandémie
les montréalais ont redécouvert leur
parc mois leur quartier les grands parcs
également j'ai eu la chance de faire un
petit reportage au parc angrignon il ya
quelques semaines un étranger un
américain ne retient qui arrive au parc
angrignon c'est une route il dit
j'aimerais prendre un petit café de rien
j'aimerais aller à la toilette ya rien
les a été blessé et le sait les deux
administrations parce que plante
monsieur coda août
votre anisation aussi est-ce qu'on a les
moyens de faire des parcs qui sont plus
accueillants pour les montréalais et oui
absolument en tout
respect on a commencé justement les
projets pilotes de toilettes publiques
dans ville-marie on avait on avait hâte
à l'est pas les auto nettoyant bon ça
c'est important oui on doit re découvre
on aurait tous croient nos parcs au
niveau de la pala avec la pandémie oui
c'est pour ça que je parlais de propreté
tantôt
toilettes à fait opaque à fond de nous
on a décidé de mettre un programme pour
aider les parcs locaux pour préparer les
vespasiennes et les parcs les locaux de
parc pour qu'on puisse qu'aller chalet
de parc voit là et ça c'est un programme
qui fonctionne très bien si vous allez
dans ville marie mercier hochelaga
maisonneuve on a décidé d'investir dans
des équipements qui servent aux familles
pour aller faire pipi ou juste pour
mettre les patins et d en face à avoir
partout et ça c'est en gras duels mais
nous on est des cdag montagny dans les
quartiers spécifiques en ce sens là et
c'est avec les arrondissements donc un
fonds de 120 millions qui touche
notamment le verdissement qui touche
aussi des services en ce sens pour les
questions en rafale pouce à cette
émission le fils
en question rafale est ce que on doit en
faire plus pour protéger le français à
montréal madame plante le sait les
questions en rafale donc je vais vous
plaît oui et c'est pour ça qu'on a un
plan de protection de valorisation de la
langue française entre avec madame
louise harel pour l'application de la
nouvelle mouture de la loi 101 et en
viennent à engager la première
commissaire à la langue française de la
ville de montréal monsieur coderre le
phrasé oui mais on a besoin d'un conseil
de la langue française tels que la
motion qu'on avait fait passer mais on
doit aussi travailler davantage sur la
francisation le statut de métropole avec
le bureau d'un test d'intégration des
nouveaux arrivants de montréal c'est une
façon de faire donc tout en donnant des
services aux autres mais je pense qu'on
devrait miser aussi en termes
d'intégration sur la francisation et
vous entendez les deux qui évidemment
pas question de revenir avec une vue le
bilan dans son arbre sur la même
longueur d'onde près histoire et
monuments historiques est ce qu'il ya
des monuments de jean nemec dans nous
aviez dit on va leur mettre en colère
parce que vous avez dit non madame
plante je sais pas où il est mais moi
c'est une lady pense qu'on doit pas fait
l'histoire les gens sont de plus en plus
sensibles à ça que on peut pas quand
même biffé l'histoire ce combat elle
l'expliqué ou non mais moi s'est excusé
c'est pas politiser pied hors de
question moi je n'étais pas très
confortable avec la position monsieur
kodak a décidé que ça changerait car et
un lieu pour la réconciliation sans même
avoir consulté les premières nations
elle même alors moi je travaille
toujours en équipe et c'est pour ça
qu'on est en train de mettre un cas de
reconnaissance qui va nous aider à
prendre des décisions mais qui ne seront
pas politique parce que c'est pas propos
nous c'est pas propre au mieux se
connaître moi c'est à propos des gens
qui vivent avec des monuments qui
viennent les chercher
oui mon achat avec des experts sas
europe au moins les travailleurs et qui
dit qu on leur mettait mais quand ça
veut pas dire que il doit être sur le
piédestal c'est dans ce sens là je parle
mais un quelqu'un qui ne connaît pas son
histoire et condamnés à la répéter odier
les oiseaux donc on a besoin on ne peut
pas déboulonner le passé et quand on
parlait place de réconciliation parce
que moi j'étais un de ceux qui a
travaillé notamment sur les pensionnats
autochtones deuxièmement sur la question
du gorille elle vous en souvenez vous
étiez correspondant parlementaire à
l'époque à ottawa donc on a on ad on a
un devoir de faire correctement et j'en
ai vous leur mettez ou moins en semaine
et je le remettrai au même niveau avec
un blake explicative
sur la fin je répète plan de monsieur
coderre
comment décririez vous votre style de
leadership monsieur kodak est ce que
vous avez quelle leçon vous avez apprise
de la fameuse formule 1 et madame
plantes quatre ans après quelles leçons
vous avez apprise en étant au pouvoir
comment vous décrivez très rapidement
c'est sûr que un moment donné faut faire
une distinction détermination et
arrogance et c'est là que des fois on a
un métro mais moi j'ai toujours eu un
leadership assumé et je suis fier d'eux
en ce sens je dirais jamais que c'est la
faute des autres volets se met
pleinement
on doit avoir ce sens des métropoles qui
nous permet de jouer un rôle pas d'être
dans salles d'attentes on a un budget de
7 milliards de dollars maintenant on
représente 50 % de la population c'est
ce que on a un rôle à jouer au québec
comme au canada ce que j'ai envie de
vous dire c'est que je suis la première
mairesse de montréal mais surtout celle
qui a traversé la coved avec une
citoyens citoyennes et dans les choses
qui m'ont le plus touché deux parmi les
nombreux témoignages si on me parlait de
ma bienveillance de notre bienveillance
de notre administration pendant cette
période difficile d'être au rendez vous
de laisser personne derrière et ça pour
moi c'est important ce n'est pas à
propos de moi mais c'est le rôle que je
représente est mon leadership je préfère
qu'il est inclusif c'est pas moi qui
décide donc moi je travaille avec
l'élite tout le monde rêvons un peu quel
serait le prochain grand projet de
montréal j'ai khadr mais je pense que on
parle beaucoup de rires premièrement on
voit se retrouver le premier projet là
c'est de retrouver mon gars c'est de
retrouver cette magie c'est de redonner
ce sens la métropole où on peut avoir
des quartiers vibrant et c'est
nécessaire tout en ayant un grand projet
il va avoir il va avoir il faut qu'on
refasse le centre-ville l'est de
montréal j'ai parlé de recouvrement
décalé vous réponde rapidement par c'est
une question concrète je donne une
réponse concrète alors ça sera 5
catherine on est bon on y met un
milliard de dollars sainte-catherine
doit être c'est notre première rue
commerciale en amérique du nord elle
sera la plus belle c'est elle qu'on va
venir visiter puis déjà avec les
aménagements sur la rue mcgill collège
le square et nous avons fait c'est de ne
pas faire identique et la sonnerie
signature qui t'apprennent se dessiner
aux deux la question se pose si vous
perdez restez-vous je connais j'ai envie
de rester ça c'est sûr mais je pense que
de plan a c'est c'est vraiment de gagner
je pense que montréal le besoin d'un
nouveau leadership montréal vous savez
ces postes en référendum sur ma
personnalité c'est les gens vont
regarder ce que l'administration
actuelle au fait dans les quatre ans et
on a une alternative à leur proposer
madame plan en 2017 moi j'avais dit oui
monsieur coderre s'était moqué de la
question vous avez décidé de quitter le
bateau alors moi je considère que si la
population veut me donner le rôle de
chef de l'opposition rôle que j'ai déjà
un p tit important pour la démocratie
identique à ce moment là je pense qu'il
faut pouvoir accepter ce verdict et
aller de l'avant mais bien sûr j'invite
tous les montréalais à voter pour projet
montréal très bien pourquoi les
montréalais devraient aller voter je
vous donne 10 secondes chacun les gens
devraient aller voter parce que c'est
important pour la démocratie et moi
j'aurais aimé que les gens de 70 ans et
plus et puces vois tu es aussi par votre
postale à cause de la pandémie mais
c'est une question de respect de
l'institution 10 55 l'éditeur tôt c'est
une élection qui est importante pour
aujourd'hui et pour demain et quand une
question 35 aux logiques on le doit à
nos enfants nos petits enfants aller
voter allons voter merci beaucoup
vraiment là vous avez été grave leur ce
soir un débat est intelligent merci
mesdames et messieurs d'avoir été là à
aller voter samedi dimanche prochain on
sera bien on se revoit le 7 novembre
l'élection
[Musique]